tonight the voice is on and you know the
premise it's looks don't matter it's all
about talent it's the blind auditions
where coaches have their chairs turned
around but once a contestant makes the
show then they need to cultivate a
little attention I'm a superstar Sophie
shalay see got a behind-the-scenes look
at how that transformation takes place
with me
tonight we learn which of the eight
finalists will compete for the title
sure they sound great but looking the
part is nearly as important I love it
and for that the artists get help from
costume designer Erin hurt a lot of
times someone wants to wear something
and it's not necessarily gonna best suit
their suit there are nice curves yeah
this wind is blowing blah blah
semi-finalist Billy Gilman check out his
transformation depends on Erin they just
come alive with ideas and they like how
are you you you be reading my mind
[Music]
country rocker Sundance has been rocking
it all season I was hoping that we were
doing this interview because you were
gonna nominate me for sexiest male
entertainer there's still time there's
still time but when it comes to his
fashion makeover he's my rhinestone
cowboy so tell us what's happening right
here how much alterations happen in a
given week well Kim builds me clothes
every week because i have this
outstanding body type that people don't
make clothes for
you
[Music]
ali caldwell gets fashion inspiration
from coach miley she ever bring you
something and you're like girl I'm not
wearing never I like she she gets me
team Levine's Brendan Fletcher has come
a long way and if it doesn't quite work
out for the finals he's hoping there
might be some lovely parting gifts now
the real big question is do you get to
take any of the stuff home with you I'm
definitely gonna get away with taking
some stuff home why do they want me to